bien mes chers
collègues mon
général on va on va démarrer excusez-moi
pour le léger retard mais on éétait pas
retenu par une patrouille de gendarmerie
je vous rassure tout va
bien nous recevons aujourd'hui le
général d'armée Christian Rodriguez
directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale pour la présentation du budget
de la gendarmerie pour 2024 mon général
c'est évidemment toujours avec un grand
plaisir que nous vous accueillons
auocénin vous qui couvrez 96 % de nos
35000 communes la gendarmerie a en effet
une relation très ancienne et
privilégiée avec les élus locaux et en
particulier ceux des communes rurales
même si elle doit aussi prendre en
compte l'extension du péri urbain et
avec lui les nouvelles formes de
délinquence comme les élus la
gendarmerie est en première ligne face
au monté des tensions sociales des
violences de tous ordre des violences
crapuleuses non crapuleuses des
violences sexuelles des violences
intrafamiliales mais aussi de des
violences urbaines et j'ai souvent
j'entends souvent mes gendarmes me dire
sont plutôt parfois assistantes social
que que gendarme mais c'est aussi un des
rôles que malheureusement nous devons
parfois tous assumer y compris les élus
et donc je veux rendre hommage mon
général à ce titre au professionnalisme
des gendarmes dans ce contexte
particulièrement difficile comme les
élus la gendarmerie doit aussi répondre
à une demande croissante de proximité
venant de nos concitoyens qui en
particulier dans les points de notre
territoire les plus enclavés ont le S
d'un reflux des services publics face à
cela le président de la République a
assigné des objectifs ambitieux à notre
gendarmerie doublement de la présence
sur la voie publique d'ici à 2030 montée
en puissance de la réserve
opérationnelle jusqu'à 50000 réservistes
à
2027 modernisation du parcours victime
lutte renforcée contre la menace cybè
passage d'une logique de guichet à une
logique d'aller vert avec notamment les
brigades itinérantes tout cela mon
général est-il crédible c'est une
question mon général le budget de la
gendarmerie pour 2024 permet-il de
répondre à ces objectifs très ambitieux
vous nous présenterai en particulier la
création annoncée voici quelques
semaines des 239 nouvelles brigades ou
238 car les deux chiffres sont annoncé
dans la documentation officielle donc
près de 2 ti3 des brigades de dont près
de 2/ers de brigades mobiles quelle
logique a présidé à la création et à la
répartition de ces brigades et surtout
quel effort en matière de moyens
financiers humain immobilier y répond la
cartographie des nouvelles brigades
s'est-elle construite avec les élus
locaux premier partenaires de la
gendarmerie autre en jeux d'importance
pour 2024 les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris dans quelle
mesure et sous quelle modalité la
gendarmerie et tout particulièrement la
réserve opérationnelle seront-elles
sollicitées sans obérer les moyens
d'évolu à leur mission ordinaire dans
nos territoirees après votre
intervention liminire je donnerai la
parole aux deux rapporteurs pour avis de
la commission pour le programme 152
Philippe Paul et Jérôme Darras puis à
l'ensemble de NS commissaires mon
général je vous laisse la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs euh vous l'avez dit monsieur
le Président entre le 26 juillet et le 8
septembre la France accueillera les Jeux
Olympique à Paris euh et qui ce
globalement Paris deviendra le
l'épicentre médiatique du monde dès lors
chaque impact de de du du moindre
événement qui se passera sur le
territoire national sera vu relayer aura
une résonance toute particulière et et
marquera durablement l'image de la
France dans la Condé des ambitions du
gouvernement et des des des ambitions
que le président a pour nous et que vous
avez rappelé monsieur le Président le et
porté par la par la lopmie qui a été
portée elle-même par le le ministre de
l'Intérieur le la gendarmerie verra son
budget global porté à 6illard 411
millions d'euros PLF 2024 contre 6ard1 7
million d'euros en LFI 2023
et je vais m'efforcer de le démontrer en
vous donnant également les les les les
points d'attention que que nous avons ce
budget nous permettra d'assumer euh les
répondre au demande de de sécurité que
les des Français ce que la population
attend de nous tout en assumant par
ailleurs les mesures générales et
catégorielles qui valorise le traitement
de nos militaires merci d'ailleurs à cet
égard pour les les propos que vous avez
tenu à à endroit de de personnels de la
maison et je je me joins à vous pour
pour saluer leur engagement au quotidien
dans les territoires dans des conditions
et des circonstances qui sont il ne sont
pas simples je suis pas certain qu'ell
soit beaucoup plus simples demain
au-delà des jeux le pays est d'ailleurs
confronté à une émergence de différents
enjeux qui peuvent être générateurs
s'ils ne sont pas anticipés de crises
qui peuvent être protéiformes mais
également concomitantes on parlait de
d'enchaînement de situation de crise
aujourd'hui on parle plutôt de
d'empilement de situation de crise mais
j'aurais l'occasion de d'y revenir et
nous nous efforçons de de de nous
organiser en conséquence en développant
une stratégie autour de trois axes qui
couvre le le spectre le plus large des
menaces je vais y revenir euh donc en
2024 la prise en compte de la demande de
sécurité de nos concitoyens demeure
naturellement une priorité au regard des
exigences croissantes de la population
en la matière à travers une présence
accrue sur le territoire ce sera ma ma
ma première partie dans le même temps
nous resterons pleinement mobilisés dans
la préservation des intérêts nationaux
face aux atteintes à l'ordre public au
flux migratoires irréguliers aux actes
terroristes ce sera ma deuxième partie
enfin nous continuerons à investir dans
les nouvelles frontières de la
délinquence et je veux parler notamment
de la lutte contre les cybermenace et la
criminalité environnementale ce sera ma
trème
partie euh dans un premier temps le
l'approche opérationnelle qui est
tournée vers la prise en compte de la
demande de sécurité avec une présence
accrue sur l'ensemble du territoire je
je dis assez régulièrement que notre
première mission n'est pas d'arrêter les
voleurs mais de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de voleurs et pour cela une
condition qui n'est pas suffisante mais
qui est nécessaire c'est d'occuper le
terrain parce que si n'occupe pas le
terrain d'autres l'occupent à notre
place et et en l'espèce la délinquance
en profite
largement et donc c'est aussi c'est pour
cela c'est ce que ce que nous a demandé
le président le président de la
République vous l'avez rappelé le
doublement de la présence de voix publi
il faut occuper le
terrain donc ce cette occupation cette
augmentation de la présence de voie
publique pour prendre des termes techno
et les indicateurs que que que nous
regardons pour être honnête c'est le
seul indicateur que je regarde
aujourd'hui c'est la présence de voies
publi pour que les gendarmes soient
effectivement sur le terrain passe déjà
par une densification inédite du
maillage territorial on a pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années 10 sous des
brigades et là on en recréé
239 sur le d'ici à 2027 les premières
dès lors que le calendrier sera un petit
peu pe préciser on pourra les créer dans
les semaines en tout cas avant avant la
fin de l'année euh et ensuite début 23
jusqu'à l'ét 23 24 jusqu'à l'été 24 on
créera les annuités donc 23 et
24 et on le fera assez rapidement mais
j'y reviendrai sur les modalités si si
si vous le souhaitez euh pour cela on a
un schéma d'emploi positif de 1045 ETP
euh la l'augmentation de la présence de
voie publique vous en avez parl passe
aussi par une augmentation de la réserve
opérationnelle avec une cible à 50000 à
l'horizon 2027 et pour cela on a une
augmentation de l'enveloppe de la
réserve opérationnelle en 2024 de 28,89
million d'euros hors cas
pension
euh puisque c'est le seul indicateur que
je que je suis je peux vous le citer
depuis le début de l'année on a une
augmentation de l'ordre de 9 % de la
présence de voies publique donc des des
gendarmes sur le un effet terrain le
halz vert vous en avez également parlé
on change un modèle
qui conduisait souvent avoir un gendarme
dans une brigade qui attendait l'arrivée
des usagers l'idée c'est de d'être
davantage dans une logique de prise de
rendez-vous et de déplacement du
gendarme vers l'usager on a commencé à
le faire pendant la crise sanitaire par
exemple les
violences fait aux femmes on l'a fait
également pour les élus de plus en plus
nombreux qui sont agressés pour faire
gagner du temps et aller prendre une
plainte par exemple à la mairie donc
l'idée c'est à terme
d'avoir une notification pour prendre ce
que ce que chacun connaît aujourd'hui
avec avec les les les téléphone que nous
avons qui permet un gendarme par exemple
d'avoir une notification en disant vous
avez rendez-vous à telle heure avec avec
Madame Duran vous votre voiture est
garée là vous avez 10 minutes pour
rejoindre la voiture vous avez un quart
d'heure pour rejoindre le domicile de
Madame durant et donc il faut que vous
partiez dans un quart d'heure euh les
technologies existent il reste à
raccorder un petit peu tout cela mais ce
sera l'affaire de pas longtemps euh et
pendant que le gendarme
euh entre deux rendez-vous en attendant
les rendez-vous il peut être auprès du
maire il peut être sur le marché il peut
aller voir les commerçants euh et en
fait il peut générer de la présence de
voie publi pour être honnête on le fera
pas dans le Var au mois d'août puisque
là pour le coup euh malheureusement on a
beaucoup de monde qui vient euh pour
déposer une plainte mais euh on a quand
même dans les 2 tiers ou les tr/4 des
départements euh les zones où il fait je
dirais bonvire et c'est plus facile de
l'organiser parce que on attend souvent
les usagers mais on passe une on a un
gendarme qui peut passer 24 heures à
attendre en fait trois ou quatre
personnes qui viendront le voir donc
l'idée c'est aussi de générer comme cela
de la de la présence de voix publi et et
d'apporter un un contact plus
confortable si j'ose dire entre entre
l'usager qui voudra déposer une plainte
ou en tout cas faire quelque chose euh
déclarer quelque chose à un gendarme ça
se fera dans des conditions qui seront
plus plus agréables je pense pour tout
le
monde donc pour ça ce c'est le le le en
fait la distribution des des appareils
néo donc les les les les téléphones dont
je parlais tout à l'heure c'est 11000
néo dans la 2e évolution euh qui euh qui
sont achetés et c'est 47000 ordinateur
portable qu'on appelle ubiquity qui
permettent en mobilité de réaliser tous
les actes que l'on est en mesure de
faire dans une brigade territoriale dans
dans dans des logements en dur c'est
aussi ce qui va nous permettre mais j'y
reviendrai si vous le souhaitez de
d'avoir des brigades mobiles qui peuvent
en fait déplacer la brigade vers vers
les usagers dans des communes où on n
pas de brigade et dans des communes où
jusqu'à présent voyez pas forcément
beaucoup de
bleus pour cela la création de l'agence
numérique des forces de sécurité
intérieur va nous permettre c'est en
fait une une amplification du service du
du stsi Carr le ce ce ce service
numérique commun au policiers et aux
gendarmes nous permet d'assurer la
maîtrise complète des outils numérique
avec une une augmentation
d'effectifs le le aujourd'hui le stsi
carré enfin aujourd'hui hier c'était 378
personnels et l'idée c'est pouvoir en 23
et en 24 le porter à 528
ETP dans le même temps toujours dans
l'idée d'aller vers et de mieux répondre
aux attentes de nos usagers il y a un
parcours victime rénové vous l'avez
évoqué qui est développé pour avoir un
accueil personnaliser un accompagnement
global l'idée c'est de c'est de ne
pas de de résister à la tentation
d'offrir des plateformes aux usagers
mais qui qui c'est une somme de bonnes
idées mais mais l'usager ne doit pas
avoir à choisir la plateforme qu'il doit
emprunter pour aller au contact des des
et même en gros la plateforme forme on
doit pas lui proposer 25 choix y compris
police ou gendarmerie et l'idée c'est
d'avoir un pardon pour le le le terme
anglais mais un frontofice qui soit
unique et qui permette en fait de guider
au gré de de de de ce que souhaite faire
l'usager de de l'aider et ce qu'il y a
derrière c'est le problème du ministère
des policiers des gendarmes donc ce
c'est c'est ce que l'on on appelle ce ce
parcours victime ça doit être facile
pour la victime et toutes les
difficultés c'est à nous de les gérer
donc c'est il y a quand même un gros
travail enfin tous ceux qui mettent un
peu les doigs dans le numérique savent
que derrière pour avoir quelque chose
qui fonctionne ça demande un peu
d'effort euh mais en tout cas c'est une
c'est quelque chose qui est important
qui démultipliera également le le d'une
part le confort des usager mais
également la performance collective des
des enquêteurs qu'il soient policiers ou
qu'il soi
gendarme ça veut dire formation donc on
développe une formation à distance qu'
qu'on a qu'on continue à développer pour
que les gens puissent se former sans se
déplacer et et la lopmie prévoit
également la création de centres
régionaux de formation qui permettront
également d'avoir des formations qui
soient au plus proche et éviter de
perdre du temps pour venir à
Fontainebleau pour pour avoir une
formation dans tel domaine parce qu'on a
le centre à Fontainebleau là on aura des
centre dans toutes les dans toutes les
régions pour être honnête mais je je je
c juste pour vous donner l'esprit dans
lequel on est mais on le fera pas en 24
l'idée c'est de tout tout nos cursus de
formation c'est de
les couper en cycle de 5 jours pour que
ça tienne sur une semaine et pour que
passer d'une formation de masse à une
formation qui soit individualisée pour
que les gendarmes qui s'estiment légers
dans un domaine s'inscrivent ou les
chefs qui estiment qu'ils ont des
personnels légers dans tel domaine les
inscrivent et quand une classe est
pleine on convoque la classe et on
assure cette formation dans les centres
régionaux une fois qu'on aura créé les
centres de formation régionaux on
passera à cet ob objectif là le gain il
est immédiat évident on ne on fait pas
de la formation de masse à des gens qui
n'en ont pas forcément besoin on on a
une formation qui est adaptée on
responsabilise les gendarmes et on
responsabilise leur chefs et comme dans
le même temps on rapproche la formation
des gendarmes euh pour les cas où il
faut du présentiel on gagnera du temps
et on gagnera également en
performance euh toujours le le l'usager
enfin le parcours usager c'est la
plainte en ligne euh avec des
expérimentations qui euh euh qui sont en
cours euh en Gironde euh on est en train
de la de la mettre en place
euh on a la visi plainte qui est l'un
des éléments de la plainte en ligne qui
est expérimenté dans les yelines et avec
une vocation également à être développé
dans d'autres département assez
rapidement la plainte en ligne l'idée
est en en 2024 d'avoir un déploiement
qui soit qui soit
national tout ça en étant euh connecté à
la procédure pénale numérique qui est un
gros chantier commun au ministère de la
Justice et au ministère de l'Intérieur
euh avec des des crédits euh on a 15ion
15 sur pour pour que l'on a récupéré
pour notre programme sur ce sujet-l
euh c'est un outil qui est compliqué
mais dès lors qu'il sera abouti on sera
sur du quasi zéro papier et de la prise
de plainte jusqu'au jugement on aura une
intégration complète euh des documents
pour que chacun puisse en avoir un usage
donc il y aura un gain de temps un gain
un gain budgétaire et puis un gain de
confort également pour l' usagers
la protection des élus j'ai évoqué les
agressions de plus en plus importantes
des élus et parlementaires y compris il
y a une structure qui a été créée en 202
fin 23 y a quelques mois au sein de mon
cabinet avec une sous-préfette et un
officier de gendarmerie qui est là pour
appuyer pour pour observer ce qui se
passe pour avoir une une vision très
précise des choses et pour appuyer
l'action des des préfets pour aider à
mieux prévenir et à mieux traiter quand
quelque chose quelque chose se produit
euh on travaille beaucoup avec la MF sur
sur ce sujet des applications que l'on
développe c'est gandes élu qui est une
application qui commence maintenant à
être très très développé on a un
référent élu par brigade on a formé des
élus à la gestion des inciivilités on
est à 23 ou 24000 élus qui ont été
formés pour mieux gérer les situations
de crise du quotidien et elles sont
nombreuses et donc l'objectif c'est
d'avoir une meilleure vision grâce à
ce ce ce centre d' de lutte contre les
atteintes faites aux élus ca dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui nousra
permettra d'avoir une réponse plus
adaptée un mot sur les les violences
intrafamiliales les violen sexuelles et
sexistes on a aussi une augmentation
importante un peu partout euh on a on a
terminer la création des maisons de
protection des familles on en a 99
désormais et les intervenant socio
gendarmerie souvent financé par les
Conseils départementaux sont maintenant
très présents et l'idée est de
d'augmenter pour la police et la
gendarmerie le le le volume en place de
de on en a 260 nous c'est d'en avoir 200
de plus euh à l'horizon 2027 et les
enquêteurs spécialement formés euh on va
continuer à les augmenter euh pour être
en mesure d'en afficher 2000 dès l'année
prochaine euh si la première de nos
missions c'est de c'est c'est d'empêcher
qu'il y ait des voleurs la deuxième de
nos mission c'est les arrêter quand il y
en a euh bien évidemment
euh la gendarmerie constate à peu près
un/ers des faits des faits constatés euh
France entière on a un taux
d'élucidation jamais euh on en rêve
toujours mieux mais pour les attintes
aux personnes par exemple alors c'est le
meilleur taux hein c'est vrai qui est de
de 78 % ce qui est ce qui est plutôt pas
mal et ensuite selon les atteintes au
bien on tourne entre 10 12 % pour les
pour les les cell où on est les moins
bons
euh à 40 40 50 % pour pour d'autres euh
là aussi on y travaille on développe pas
mal d'algorithmes également pour euh euh
pour être capable de de de d'être plus
présent mais j'y reviendrai si vous avez
des questions mais il me semble que j'en
avais déjà parlé l'année
dernière maîtrise au stock de procédure
c'est aussi été un un vrai sujet à ce
stade on n' pas de difficulté pour
maîtriser les stock des procédures
euh donc pourvu que ça dure on sera aidé
en cela par la densification de la
formation à la poli judiciaire qui a été
souhaité également par le Président de
la République euh dans les écoles euh en
fait on augmente la formation de 9 à 12
mois on a ajouté un module de 120h de
renforcement cours de renforcement de
police judiciaire
ce qui permettra désormais à nos
gendarmes siôt sorti de l'école de
tenter le diplôme d'officier de police
judiciaire sans attendre les 3 ans
d'ancienneté comme c'était le cas
jusqu'à
présent donc on aura davantage d'OPJ et
dans le même temps nos réservistes et je
reviendrai sur les réservistes les
anciens OPG réservistes pourront à
nouveau être OPG ce qui n'était pas le
cas jusqu'à
présent mon deuxième point sur le le le
le notre action vers la préservation de
républicain la protection des intérêts
nationaux j'ai évoqué ce contexte on
observe une
augmentation très marquée des des des
violences de tout ce qui quelque part
symbolise l'État de droit le le le le
l'ordre l'économie euh
l'autorité et et pour le coup on a c'est
c'est c'est des choses que l'on observe
qu'on a observé en de manière assez
importante en 2023 avec des
contestations qui sont de plus en plus
htérogènes avec des des
CSP dans dans les gens qu'on interpelle
on a absolument de tout je vous donne un
exemple en région
lyonnaise alors d'une manière générale
les les atteintes au relais de 5g sont
sont assez classiques avec des discours
la 5G c'est le mal ça donne ça donne
plein de
maladies puis la terre est plate et puis
bon on a quandême arrêté des moines qui
ont attaqué un relais
5G donc sont tout peu arrivé
euh et euh alors on na jamais eu
réellement l'explication de du passage à
l'acte mais en fait on observe malgré
tout qu'aujourd'hui entre les réseaux
sociaux le fait algorithmique qui fait
qu'on que que vous n'avez sur sur les
réseaux auquel vous connecter que les
informations qui vous intéressent ça ça
exacerbe en fait certaines certitudes
que que l'on peut avoir on a de plus en
plus de gens qui considèrent que la
terre est plate et comme vous n'allez
regarder que les informations qui
concernent la Terre plate le les
algorithmes vont vous donner ces
informations là et du coup on a des
communautés qui son qui sonent de plus
en plus fortes où la fin du monde est
pour demain on a eu plusieurs cas de de
gens qui ont tué leurs voisins leur et
qui ensuite ont voulu se faire tuer par
des policiers ou par des
gendarmes et ces phénomènes là on les
retrouve assez facilement je veux pas
faire de sociologie de comptoir mais la
crise sanitaire a emplifier encore les
fragilités avec des gens qui ont arrêté
de se soigner et aujourd'hui auouri on a
pare je dirais le truc assez classique
c'est l'homme qui bat sa femme quand les
gendarmes interviennent et tirent sur
les gendarmes on a globalement toutes
les deux nuits des gendarmes qui sont
tirés
dessus toutes les 30 minutes on a une
voitures qui fon sur les gendarmes et
quand on en arrête quand même beaucoup
mais on peut foncer sur les gendarmes
parce qu'on a plus de point ou parce que
on dit on passera à
côté le le la
légitimité et
le en fait il y a une forme de
désinhibition et que que l'on retrouve
un petit peu partout je vous donne un
autre exemple et je m'en arrêterai là
saint Soline j'ai entendu de nombreuses
fois y compris dans les médias le
certain M dit mais si vous n'aviez pas
été là il y aurait pas eu de
violence c'est imparable c'est imparable
c'est vrai que si entre les bassines et
les gens qui les black blocks que l'on a
observé s'il av pas eu de gendarmes pour
le coup il y aurait pas eu de violence
en tout cas entre les black block et les
gendarmes faute de
gendarmes et mais en fait ce discours
est considéré comme légitime par
beaucoup et je vous passe moi les gens à
qui je fais des remarques sur la route
dans Paris qui roule n'importe comment
ou un moment où en fait ça leur paraît
surprenant que je puisse leur dire que
ce qu'ils ont fait est
interdit j'y reviendrai si vous le si
vous le souhaitez en tout cas bon j'ai
évoqué
syonine 146 militaires blessés
sur sur la période Saintine à
retraite alors que l'année des gilets
jaunes en 2019 sur toute l'année on en a
eu 139 donc je parle de blessé de
blessés
sérieux donc on a on a vraiment cette
augmentation de la violence j'y
reviendrai c'est si si vous avez des
questions sur ces sujets mais c'est
c'est un sujet de préoccupation
oui dans l'absolu en tout cas c'est
quelque chose contre lequel on on
s'organise pour pour être davantage
présent et être et et être et être
meilleur donc ça passe par
l'accompagnement des personnels mais ça
passe également par le durcissement de
la formation de nos personnel si on y
ajoute des engagements du type Ukraine
Soudan Burkina Faso Libye où on a engagé
des gendarmes et pas que du
GIGN également des excants de
gendarmerie mobile sur ces pointslà en
fait on a assez vite compris et
d'ailleurs c'est le drame d'Amber qui
nous qui nous a réveillé là-dessus qu'on
avait intérêt à durcir la formation no
personnel concrètement nos escadrons et
on est aidé en cela j'en reviens au
sujet budgétaire par l'arrivée des des
hélicoptères h160 qui sont des
hélicoptères de manœuvre des blindés des
blindés sor avec on a les 30 premiers
qui sont actuellement à à satori qui
sont des engins qui sont juste
extraordinaires entre les blindés et les
hélicoptères on va redécouvrir ce que
l'on faisait quand quand j'étais jeune
en début de carrière c'est
l'aéromobilité et et la la projection de
capacité aux endroits où a besoin de
quelque chose sur des situations de
crise très tendu donc mon rôle c'est de
proposer aussi cette de de de que la
gendarmerie soit capable de d'y faire
face c'est des c'est des choses je je
dis pas que ça arrivera mais en tout cas
notre rôle c'est de ne pas être surpris
et face à cette augmentation de la
violence on l'a vu sur les violences
urbaines de de l'été dernier il faut
qu'on élève notre niveau de notre niveau
de formation donc on on refait de la
formation de de combat de la manœuvre
sous sous le feu pour le coup toutes les
deux nuits ça nous sert euh nos PSIG on
est sur la dernière annuité de
transformation des postes de gendarme
volontaire en PO de sous-officiers de
gendarmerie on on a eu TR fois 1000
transformations de poste on est en train
de de de former davantage même dans nos
brigades des spécialistes en
intervention professionnelle pour
maîtriser quelqu'un en limitant les
risques que l'on fait courir à la
personne qu'on maîtrise notre but c'est
quand même d'interpellerer les gens sans
les neutraliser
sans en limitant les risqu c'est la
création de deux escadrons qu'on a
appelé guépard qu'on a durci qui sont à
satori qui sont capables d'utiliser
l'ensemble du spectre
des des moyens dont nous sommes dotés
sur les situations de de crise extrême
euh et on va continuer à
travailler-dessus mais j'y reviendrai si
vous le si vous le souhaitez et puis
tout ça sans oublier les menaces
nouvelles c'est les drones donc on a
aussi un développement de capacité de
lutte antidrone c'est le programme qui
permet aussi d'avoir un
système qu'on appelait radio avant mais
maintenant c'est c'est beaucoup plus que
de la simple radio parce que si on ne
communique pas on peut pas commander on
peut pas manœuvrer donc Storm qui sera
qui est déjà expérimenté dans plusieurs
départements
donloise depuis depuis quelques mois qui
sera en œuvre pendant les pendant les
Jeux
Olympiques alors sur sur pendant les
jeux on va
la plaque île-de-fance puisque c'est le
centre de gravité de mais en fait
partout où on a les jeux on va essayer
d'y mettre d'y mettre Storm et l'idée
c'est de généraliser cela juste après
donc ça tout ça va arriver très très
vite la préfecture de police
l'expérimente déjà euh et en fait quand
on on teste auprès auprès des agents
policiers et gendarmes c'est un un
réseau qui est commun et qui est
complètement interopérable
donc donc en volume de de poste 35000
35000 he c'est ça aujourd'hui
euh on vous donnera le CH je vous
donnerai le chiffre précis mais euh mais
mais en tout cas ça marche tellement
bien que tout le monde les réclame à
correct est-ce que je ce que je peux
comprendre euh et dans lois ils en sont
contents donc euh l'engagement sur les
la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière c'est aussi un une manœuvre
de tous les instants aux frontières de
métropole mais également are mer euh on
a 94 % du L du linéaire frontalier
national donc de fait on y est engagé
c'est le cas dans les départements 06 05
bien sûr mais également la frontière
espagnole puisque les flux varient aussi
assez régulièrement de l'Italie vers
l'Espagne donc c'est une mission qui est
partagée voilà 35000 en fin 23 on aura
35000 postes Storm
euh donc avec avec l'expérimentation
border force qui est également partagé
entre la la police et la gendarmerie euh
c'est aussi une une action euh dans les
outresmers guyan Mayotte avec
l'opération wambouchou euh et
régulièrement des opérations euh euh
appelées tempêt où on a encore récemment
euh travaillé contre les les les les les
gangs qui sont en place et ceux qui
vivent du la location d'habitat indignes
et qui contribuent aussi euh à une
immigration importante euh le centre de
rétention administrative de de Lyon est
également placé euh temporairement sur
la responsabilité de la gendarmerie et
on travaille avec la police et la la PAF
étant ayant le lit sur cette mission là
pour pour essayer d'être plus présent et
plus performant sur sur ce sujet chaque
jour c'est à peu près 1000 gendarmes qui
sont engagés sur la mission sur cette
mission de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière euh un petit focus sur le
Nord puisque avec les accords de Sanders
on a les Anglais qui finance une partie
importante de de de notre action dans
dans ce domainel euh sont des des
ressources extra budgétaires on a chaque
jour 28 241 réservistes engagés dans le
dans le Nord pour la mission et avec un
plan de financement conjoint 202326 qui
s'élève à 540,3 million d'euros dont
près de 300 millions d'euros pour la
gendarmerie des achats d'hélicoptères
des des locaux réflections de
locaux là aussi j'y reviendrai si vous
le souhaitez mon dernier point sur les
nouvelles frontières de la délincance le
cyber monsieur le président ident vous
l' vous l'avez évoqué alors c'est enfin
c'est pour moi c'est une obsession je
dirais le cyber et le numérique parce
qu'en fait derrière le cyber se peuvent
se cacher beaucoup de choses le le
ministère s'est organisé avec la
création d'un service à compétence
nationale les décrets viennent de sortir
qui était notre com cyber gendarmerie
qui devient le com cyber du
ministère qui don dont la mission
globalement sera de de de d'être en
mesure de d'avoir regard sur la menace
qui pèse en étant connecté avec
l'ensemble des services qui le qui le
font l'an bien évidemment mais le le com
cber des armées également les grands
groupes les les grands groupes qui qui
qui suivent aussi le le le la menace il
y a une une grosse fluidité de de du
partage de l'information ces derniers
temps notamment depuis la la guerre en
Ukraine c'est aussi là que l'on aura les
compét du haut du spectre qui permettent
de de d'aller traquer des délinquants
qui sont de plus en plus imaginatifs et
euh et
qui comment dire progresse très très
vite pour la petite histoire on parle
beaucoup de de Lia génératif de chat GPT
ou autre aujourd'hui le li générative
est capable de coder des r logiciels
alors beaucoup moins bien que les
hyperspécialistes mais ils le font vite
et ils le font assez facilement donc ça
demande aussi de de développer des
compétences dans ces dans ces
champsl aujourd'hui si on veut travail
est contre le blanchiment de l'argent ou
démonter des groupes criminels il faut
savoir tracer le le les mouvements
d'argent et aujourd'hui les mouvements
d'argent c'est beaucoup c'est c'est il
faut s'intéresser à la blockchain pour
être capable de détecter ce qu'il se
passe ça demande aussi de développer des
compétences particulières et on observe
je je rencontrai hier
les le patron d'une l'agence fédérale
britannique l'agence nationale
britannique qui qui qui traite les
notamment les sujets cyber et de et de
criminalité é organisé et en fait on a
des connexions entre le le le ceux qui
vendent de la drogue qui vont avoir du
cash et qui veulent blanchir l'argent et
les groupes qui à un moment donné ont
besoin de transformer de la crypto en
cash donc en fait il y a un mélange
aussi pour une forme de de la banque la
banque du crime si jeose dire avec des
mises en relation qui peuvent déjà
exister naturellement et spontanément et
qui en plus pour des besoins
logistiques se parle et travaill
ensemble de l'intérêt d'avoir un regard
assez pointu sur ce qui se passe et donc
c'est typiquement des spécialistes en
crypto et en blockchain que ce que nous
faisons notamment à travers le centre de
de formation qui a été ouvert à Lille
fin d'année dernière qui et qui est
maintenant qui fonctionne maintenant à
un rythme normal et que nous allons
continuons à continuer à monter en
compétence du fait également des crédits
en en l'opni euh dans le même tempsueer
à travailler auprès des jeunes parce que
ce que nous demandent nos concitoyens
c'est pas d'arrêter les hackurs c'est de
ne pas être hacké je continue sur le
même discours ça veut dire qu'il faut
sensibiliser dès le début tout le monde
donc on le fait avec l'AMF notamment
auprès des collectivités en développant
des outils d'autodiagnosticque pour
ensuite pour sensibiliser tout le monde
parce que le niveau de sensibilisation
est pas pas optimum si si je dire face à
des sujets faut d'avoir une connaissance
précise de ce à quoi on a on a affaire
euh c'est également le permis internet
que nous faisons avec avec AXA euh ça
fait 10 ans que nous nous allons dans
les classes de CM2 pour expliquer à des
jeunes alors au début l'idée était de
dire attention sur le sur internet il y
a des prédateurs maintenant on continue
à porter ce message mais attention on ne
fait pas n'importe quoi qu'une clé
USB sachant que dans l'entreprise ou
dans les administrations j'ai deux fils
qui sont ingénieurs en sécurité
informatique qui me disent qu'en fait le
le la vulnérabilité principale elle se
trouve entre le clavier et le dossier du
fauteuil donc il faut que expliquer à
celui qui est assis sur le fauteuil
qu'on ne on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
on ne clique pas sur n'importe quel lien
encore faut-il le savoir et je pense que
vous avez tous des des des hackeurs qui
vous envoient des SMS pour vous demander
d'appuyer sur un
lien vous avez même sans doute des gens
qui je vous envoie je vous écris pour
vous traiter de de de pédophilie et de
vous oui oui je le fais assez souvent je
m'écris aussi d'ailleurs en vous disant
que vous allez poursuiv en justice
si bon pour la petite histoire je reçois
chaque semaine des
checs de gens qui pensent que c'est vrai
et qui sont prêts à payer à payer 5 à
10000 € pour l'abandon des poursuites
judiciaires alors là la bonne la bonne
nouvelle c'est que je n'encaisse pas
l'échec même si l'cun pourrait me dire
que ça pourrait aider le budget mais la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que quand on est
prêt à payer and DESS c'est a intérêt à
sintéresser à ce qu'il a sur
l'ordinateur donc on démarre une
enquête j'auris des tas d'anecdotes mais
pardon
oui oui je le dis mais je je l'assume je
l'assume
mais c'est en fait mais c'est le au
contraire moi ça me permet de de de
porter ce discours là de il y a des tas
de choses qui arrivent par mail ou par
SMS il faut il faut être sur ses gardes
en permanence tout le monde peut se
faire avoir donc non mais qu'on soit
capté est une excellente chose Monsieur
le Président
euh je je vais bientôt finir on est
depuis 2013 en fait on a sensibilisé
près d'un million de enfin plus d'un
million d'élèves
euh et on continue à développer en
interne les compétences que que que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure on a 10000 cyber
gendarmes euh alors avec des niveaux de
compétences le le le qui qui sont qui
sont assez variables avec un un spectre
large mais les hyperspécialistes on en a
mis 650 aujourd'hui euh et en fait le
contentieux il s'étend à une vitesse
juste phénoménale et le ce com cyber du
ministère de l'intérieur avec les
services enquêteurs de chacune des
maisons du ministère euh nous permet
aujourd'hui d'être mieux armé
collectivement euh pour pour pour lutter
contre contre ces contre ces sujets
là euh un mot sur les ce ser j'en arrive
à la fin sur le les sujets
environnementaux et de et de santé
publique on a en 2023 créé notre
commandement de l'environnement et de la
santé le
sésane qui est en fait
une une élévation du niveau de l'ancien
office l'laesp l'Office central de lutte
contre les attates à l'environnement et
la santé publique pour à l'image de ce
qui a été fait pour le la lutte contre
la drogue avec le lofaste pour avoir un
coup complet si j'ose dire entre la prév
l'aide à la normalisation pour pour pour
pour pour préciser un petit peu ce qu'il
en est la le fait de mettre tout le
monde dans une unité puisque on c'est
c'est une unité qui ratisse large avec
des policiers des agents de
l'ofb on a encore quelques connexion à
faire mais pour être plus performant sur
un sujet qui est compliqué et avec une
attente forte de la
population on a tous les jours des
dossiers importants qui qui tournent il
faut dire que le les attates à
l'environnement je crois c'est 16 ou 17
codes différents qui en parlent et on
peut faire beaucoup d'argent sans
prendre beaucoup de risque enfin on
pouvait aujourd'hui on on est vraiment
monter en compét et ça permet tout le
monde monte en compétence les magistrats
montent en compéten sur des su
compliqués et ça permet en tout cas
d'unifier d'avoir un regard
plus mieux partagé que ça n'était
jusqu'à présent je crois que je déjeune
demain AC le patron de l'ofb les choses
avancent très très bien
euh je je donne comme exemple parce que
certains d'entre vous ont sans doute eu
l'occasion d'aller en guyan c'est le cas
de l'orpaillage par exemple avec quand
on quand on voit ce qu'on déverse ce que
déverse les orpailleurs illégaux dans
les fleuves c'est catastrophique alors
qu'il y a des peuples qui vivent dans et
des fleuves on voit des gamins se
baigner dans les fleuves quand on quand
on va un petit peu en jungle et quand on
voit ce que ce qui
apparaît juste un mot pour vous faire le
lien avec un sujet précédent moi les
magistrats m'ont dit le mercure qu'on
déverse il vient d'un pays l'or va dans
le même pays P donc à un moment donné il
est intéressant de s'intéresser à la
façon dont les choses se passent et là
aussi c'est un développement enfin en
fait il faut suivre l'argent c'est ce
que fait la DEA dans une région assez
proche follow the money donc crypto
blockchain donc c'est vraiment besoin de
monter de monter en
compétence on fait aussi des choses
contre les incendies notamment pour les
enquête on développe des équipes
cinophiles qui peuvent détecter des
produits accélérants on a eu en 2020
22 un été compliqué en 2023 aussi mais
on n jamais arrêté autant d'incendiaire
alors il y a eu
aussi je je je dirais que le le les gens
assez spontanément nous ont indiqué ce
qu'ils avaient vu des voitures ce qui a
aidé les enquêteur bien évidemment et
puis on a développé des compétences
aussi pour aller pour aller tout de
suite à l'essentiel faire des
prélèvements sur le terrain avec avec un
travail entre entre les les pompiers les
gendarmes les policiers qui qui a permis
d'interpellerer beaucoup oup alors c'est
pas rassurant par que le mieux c'est que
ça ne brûle pas mais en tout cas ça a
quand même permis de de de neutraliser
des équipes qui qui allumaient ses
incendies et là aussi de de des gens de
tous
horizon
euh je vais conclure en disant que
globalement on est on est bien sûr très
engagé vous l'avez dit les les gendarmes
le sont avec un budget qui est un bon
budget modulo le fait qu'on doit prendre
à notre compte les les les mesures
générales et le et le point d'indice
mais comme toutes les
administrations et avec un point
d'attention important qui est
l'immobilier P que le rapporteur se
prépare à me poser des questions sur
l'immobilier euh c'est un vrai sujet
parce que le le
gendarme il tient les territoires les
terrains ENF les immensités des des
territoires parce qu'il est militaire
donc on ne surpaye pas un engagement de
la nuit de samedi à dimanche et parce
que et parce qu'il habite sur place
c'estàd que quand on a besoin de lui on
a alors même s'il est en en vacances ou
pas à Ambert par exemple le le le cette
nuit entre Noël et NouvelAn où on a
trois gendarmes qui ont été abatttu par
un survivaliste la moitié des gendarmes
qui ont été engagés sur le terrain quand
j'y suis la moitié était en vacances et
comme les gens habitent là quand on les
appelle il quand il y a quelque chose de
sérieux ils se posent pas de questions
ils viennent or on ne peut pas imposer
aux gendarmes d'habiter un logement si
on n'est pas capable de de de déloger
correctement sur le locatif on n pas
trop de difficulté la majorité des
brigades c'est du locatif sur les 239
brigades que nous créerons euh c'est
c'est en fait c'est les collectivités
qui assument la construction
alors on a nous on est locataire il y a
15 ans on était des mauvais locataires
aujourd'hui on paye Ruby sur l'ongle on
a assoupli un certain nombre de choses
Bercy a élevé de 15 % le niveau du loyer
que l'on peut verser
donc aujourd'hui on ne perd pas d'argent
en construisant une brigade et je parle
même pas du fait d'avoir des familles
sur une sur sur une collectivité bon on
fait pas fortune en con de brigade je
pas non plus vous vendre l'impossible
mais globalement c'est pas y a pas de
risque en plus les brigades que l'on
crée on les ferme plus sauf si tombe en
ruine parce que un moment donné après on
est dans une relation du bailleur et et
de nous qui louons
mais on on est on va encore avancer sur
le la simplification de la construction
pour que ça a plus vite et puis on a
avancé également sur la simplification
des référentiels par exemple on n'est
pas aujourd'hui on ne construit plus
systématiquement deux cellules de garde
à vue dans chacune des brigades que l'on
construit il y a des endroits où il y a
quasi pas de garde à vue ministre n le
dit assez souvent on visite des brigade
on voit des locaux de garde à vue qui
sont des locaux d'archives c'est stupide
de payer autant pour un local si c'est
pour y mettre des archives donc on
repense également tout cela d'ailleurs
la garde à vue elle-même évolue en soi
donc donc ça minore le coût de la
construction et ça rend moins compliqué
l'équilibre budgétaire de la
construction de la brigade donc c'est
pas un sujet locatif mais le domanial
donc on a en mè carré moitié moitié à
peu près le domanial c'est un vrai sujet
parce que pendant des dizaines d'années
on a rien on a on a laissé filer donc
c'est la faute à tout le monde et à
personne euh mais l'omaniel est pas dans
un bel état du tout on a quelques
brigades endomaniniales en Bretagne on a
quelquesunes notamment euh mais c'est
sur ce sont surtout les grosses casernes
et en l'opmie pour la première fois on
évoque la possibilité d'aller sur des
contrats de partenariat les PPP pour
reprendre les termes anciens et donc je
considère que jusqu'à présent on était
dans un tunnel et on savait pas où où se
terminait le tunnel là on voit de la
lumière alors le tunnel il va être long
on va pas basculer 40 ans de d'oubli ou
au lieu de 300 millions d'euros on avait
beaucoup moins euh mais mais il y a de
la lumière et donc on va l'idée est de
commencer dès 24 il y a des crédits qui
ont été mis pour cela sur des grands
projets pour qu'on puisse enfin aller
reconstruire soit soit construire soit
reconstruire des de de grandes casernes
qui jusqu'à présent tombaient plutôt en
ruine qu'autre chose voilà monsieur le
Président désolé d'avoir été un petit
peu long et je suis à votre disposition
bien évidemment pour questions que vous
souhaiteriez me poser merci beaucoup mon
général je suis tené sur vos propos sur
les gardes à vu intéressant ENF c'est
comme sur Soline s'il y avit pas de
gendarmes il y aurait pas de gardes à
vue he
c'est c'est vrai
aussi mais il faut se méfier des
transformations en Archiv ou en salle de
restauration puis qu' un jour ça peut
arriver quand même
euh je laisse la parole au rapporteur
pour avis et puis ensuite j'ai quelques
demandes de question notamment pour le
rapport 129 sur le cyber et donc la
parole est à Philippe Paul merci
monsieur le Président bien merci mon
général pour votre présentation euh il y
a eu beaucoup de communications de fait
récemment en particulier au niveau des
brigades nouvelles donc c'est une bonne
chose donc on s'attendait à ce que le
budget de la gendarmerie soit très
solide et que tout les voyons soit auou
vert or lorsque j'ai lu le budget
c'était un petit peu la douche froide
parce que je m'attendais une
augmentation conséquente des crédit donc
j'ai calculé je crois que c'est grosso
modo 4,8 % donc ce fait un petit peu
moins de 500 millions en plus sur le
budget 2024 par rapport à 2023 et vous
avez dit mon général tout à l'heure que
il y avait des choses des des éléments
non contrôlés qui venaient perturber
cette augmentation du du budget j'ai vu
les mesures guirini en matière de solld
donc 120 millions d'euros plus des
mesures
interministérielles gouvernementales 110
millions d'euros donc si je calcule bien
ça fait déjà 290 millions en moins et
puis l'inflation estimée à plus de 100
millions d'euros donc sur les 500 ou 480
millions d'euros de plus il y a déjà un
gros trou dans la raquette à la hauteur
de presque 400 millions d'euros donc
c'est un
peu bon c'est pas c'est pas vraiment
satisfaisant euh par ailleurs vous avez
évoqué euh l'immobilier je vais revenir
tout à l'heure mais il y avait depuis
que je suis euh rapporteur du budget de
la gendarm Henry il y avait deux signaux
importants tous les ans qu'on devait un
automatiquement retrouver pour
l'immobilier ça avait été estimé par vos
services d'ailleurs il y a de nombreuses
années le besoin impérieux nécessaire
d'avoir tous les ans 300 millions
d'euros pour l'immobilier 200 pour euh
les travaux d'entretien 100 pour le neuf
là je constate tout simplement ement que
c'est un vrai effondrement je vérifie ma
fiche j'ai bien vu c'est 108 millions
donc c'est quand même un un gros trou
par rapport à ce qui est nécessaire et
puis l'autre sujet aussi qu' vous n'avez
pas évoqué c'est les véhicules on avait
estimé au niveau des véhicules légers un
besoin impératif tous les ans pour que
ça tourne de plus de 3500 véhicules et
là si j'ai bien chaussé mes lunettes on
tombe à 500 véhicules donc il y a quand
même de de vecteurs extrêmement
importants pour la gendarmerie qui sont
plutôt en période de de base m euh ça
c'était le premier point le deuxième bon
sur l'immobilier justement euh vous avez
présenté de façon générale la façon don
les choses évoluent de façon plutôt à
votre avis de positive moi je bon je
vais pas parler du finisterère mais j'ai
deux cas entre guillemets que peut-être
des collègues ont de façon un peu
similaire dans leur département j'ai le
cas d'une brigade qui a une construction
de prévue en cours depuis des années les
plis ont été ouverts il y a 30 % de plus
donc ils savent pas comment faire bon
j'ai envoyé un petit courrier à votre
Ministre de tutelle pour demander si la
gendarmerie pouvait mettre un petit peu
plus de sous j'ai toujours pas de
réponse donc peut-être vous avez des
éléments peut-être que c'est conclu
convenu dans les 15 % que vous évoquez
donc ça c'est un sujet Comment c'est que
ça et donc ça c'est un premier point
sont des brigades qui sont en cours quoi
c'est pas les brigades nouvelles hein
donc dû justement à l'inflation et puis
l'autre sujet aussi c'est par rapport à
une autre un autre projet de
construction beaucoup plus important
dans le centre finisterère avec 80
logement le problème c'est que c'est un
bailleur social qui va construire le qui
devrait construire la caserne en
question à la seule différence c'est
qu'ils ont demandé la garantie de la
mairie où va être implantée la caserne
or pour garantir le prêt en question le
code des collectivités territoriales
interdit aux collectivités de de
garantir des emprunts à plus de 50 % des
recettes de de fonctionnement donc c'est
14 millions d'euros la caserne le les
recettes de fonctionnement de la commune
c'est 7 millions donc peut pas garantir
ils peuvent pas garantir donc voilà deux
deux exemples qui sont un peu euh qui
sont vraiment criants et comment faire
dans ce cas-là alors pour le deuxième
cas on dit bah la communauté de commune
n'a plus qu'à garantir l'empreunt ou
alors le Conseil départemental mais je
crois pas que l'un ou l'autre et l'autre
plutôt soit favorable à ce genre de chos
voilà grosso modo les sujets de
préoccupation mais peut-être des
collègues ont des cas similaires ou
différents dans les autres département
et puis ben pour les brigades nouvelles
j'espère qu'aussi que pour les brigades
d'étendure pour ce qui est de
l'immobilier euh les chos font leur
cours naturellement merci mon Général
Jas merci monsieur le Président merci
mon général pour votre présentation à la
fois détaillée et claire je fais mienne
les interrogations de mon collègue
corrapporteur sur le budget dans son
ensemble certes il respecte les
engagements de la loi de programmation
mais dans dans un contexte économique
caractérisé par une forte inflation et
avec une masse salariale beaucoup plus
importante que prévue même si nous nous
réjouissons des effectifs
supplémentaires et de la juste évolution
du salaire de nos gendarmes mais cela
emporte aussi des contraintes forte sur
l'investissement général et sur
l'immobilier en particulier ainsi que
sur le parc des véhicules légers comme
cela a été justement souligné je
voudrais quant à moi mon Général ajouter
trois questions une sur le matériel une
sur le recrutement et une sur la réserve
sur le matériel l'acquisition par la
gendarmerie vous l'avez évoqué
d'hélicoptère h160 de dernière
technologie permet de réaliser un bon
capacitaire avec non seulement un
renforcement de l'offre de sécurité
quotidienne des populations et des
territoires mais aussi un décuplement de
la réponse aérienne dans le cadre de la
mission de contre-terrorisme il semble
que l'industriel connaisse des
difficultés à fournir des machines
complètes à échéance pouvez-vous nous
préci nous préciseer les dates de
livraison prévues pour ces matériels les
premières seront-elles bien assurées dès
2024 s'agissant également du
renouvellement des blindés pouvez-vous
nous préciser comment sera déployé le
programme Centor au sein des unités de
gendarmerie escadron de gendarmerie
mobile antenne GIGN Centre national
d'entraitement des forces de gendarmerie
par exemple deuxème question sur le
recrutement et les départs anticiper des
informations préoccupantes remontent sur
les difficultés de recrutement et de
fidélisation des gendarmes la presse a
citer le chiffre de 3000 départs non
prévus en 2023 et évoquer une baisse
possible du nombre des une baisse du
nombre des candidatures au concours
notamment pour les sousoficiers les
sous-officiers avec pour conséquence
possible une baisse du niveau vous vous
êtes montré rassurant lors de votre
audition à l'Assemblée les national mais
un jeune qui entre dans la gendarmerie
aujourd'hui envisage-t-il d'y faire
toute sa carrière avec les fortes
contraintes vous les avez rappelé
qu'impliquent le casernement et les
mutations les 1045 nouveaux postes
annoncé pour 2024 seront-ils ainsi
pourvu durablement sans difficulté enfin
sur la réserve la montée en puissance de
la réserve opérationnelle est une
nécessité au vu de l'objectif de 100000
réservistes que vous avez rappelé en
2027 fixé par le président de la
République dans mon département du
pastecalis dans le cadre du du traité
standers les réservistes sont très
sollicités pour la surveillance de la
côte afin de détecter les franchissement
de la Manche par des embarcations
affraitées par les passeurs vous avez
cité devant nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale et vous l'avez rappelé à
nouveau ce matin le chiffre de 241
réservistes engagés tous les jours pour
un total de 2000 réservistes employé
quotidiennement donc c'est énorme la
gendarmerie a-t-elle une doctrine
d'emploi arrêtée sur la réserve les
réservistes sont-ils destinés à
supplerer les gendarmes d'Activ à les
accompagner et à les assister ou
peuvent-ils dans certaines circonstances
et sous certaines conditions se
substituer totalement à eux à cet égard
quel bilan qualitatif et qualitatif
faites-vous de leur mobilisation en 2023
et quelles sont les perspectives pour
2024 je pense vous l'avez rappelé en
particulier aux Jeux Olympiques je vous
remercie merci mon général je vous
laisse rappor rapporter répondre aux
deux rapporteurs s'il vous plaît puis
ensuite je passerai aux questions une
minute merci beaucoup oui merci monsieur
le Président alors je vais commencer par
les dernières question après je par je
parlerai de l'immobilier sur le sur le
matériel vous avez raison
Airbus à l'origine on pensait qu'on
aurait les premiers H60 avant les Jeux
et en fait euh il il y a des des
difficultés d'approvisionnement sur
certains certaines comment dire
capacités spécifique qu'il n'ont que qu'
ne serait pas en mesure qu' ne seront
pas en mesure de de d'installer sur les
machines avant donc il nous ont proposé
de nous livrer des machines sans ces
capacités là avant les Jeux pour les
installer après
euh moi j'ai préféré ne pas prendre pour
plutôt avoir la machine complète euh
pour éviter qu'à un moment donné on est
des allers-retours donc en
gros on ne s'en servira pas pour les
jeux c'est pas tellement un sujet en
réalité sur ce ce ce transport on a nos
1445 quiue à voler bien évidemment
heureusement donc concrètement les
premières machines on les espère pour la
fin
24 sur les Centor on a donc on a
aujourd'hui une
trentaine tout est actuellement à satori
il faut former les pilotes le c'est un
engin nouv nouvelle génération moi j'ai
par exemple le permis du VBRG qui
continue à rouler mais le VBRG c'est un
gros c'est un poids lourd avec peu de
visibilité le sentor on conduit avec des
écrans essentiellement et ça demande
vraiment c'est un vrai pilotage donc on
a des simulateurs qui nous ont été livré
également à satoré et on forme les les
les pilotes aujourd'hui on est capable
d'engager l'équivalent de de de de 4
Centor avec des pilotes qui sont fait
les formateurs et et et on en forme en
permanence j'ai rencontré il y a 2 jours
les les les gens qui sont sur en
formation
santor Infiné quand on aura les 90
véhicules l'idée c'est d'en avoir à
satori puisque c'est bon la plaque
parisienne est potentiellement quand
même plus consommatrice en terme de
maintien de l'ordre dur et puis depuis
Paris on peut en projeter à peu près
n'importe où même en mettant des des des
blindés dans un A400 m par exemple pour
les envoyer à l'étranger ou outre mer on
en aura ensuite dans les régions on a on
est en train de travailler sur le la
face dont on on positionne des
structures de soutien opérationnel des
véhicules dans les régions et là il
faudra un soutien plus plus donc on est
sur combien on a d'implantation au final
17 17 Sam implantation on a on
a h implantations lourdes et donc sur
ces h implantations on fera correspondre
le positionnement des des véhicules
blindés on est en train de réfléchir si
on prend des pilotes dans les escadrons
qui sont à proximité ou si on le fait
faire que par les escadrons du du
groupement blindé de
satori en réalité les interrogations que
l'on a sont pas tant sur les compétences
que sur le l'attractivité du métier de G
mobile parce que les si les pilotes ne
sont que là en attendant les tartards et
ne et ne sont pas engagés ça va pas
attirer donc donc donc voilà ce sont des
comp des des sujets RH qui vont
conditionner le la façon dont on
prévoira les pilotes et on va en envoyer
outrem outremer on a des VBRG partout
qui tournent au profit du maintien de l'
mais également euh pour les antennes
GIGN euh les contraintes que l'on aura
c'est qu'il faut construire des hangars
parce que les en sont plus haut euh donc
il y a des endroits où on ira un petit
peu moins vite parce qu'il faut trouver
le terrain et puis puis il faudra aussi
des des crédits pour le pour les les les
les faire tourner et enfin pour pour les
construire mais dans le même temps c'est
outreom que nos VBRG ou nos VAB on a des
véhicules de l'avant blindé notamment
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui ont été
surblindés c'est là comme il tournne
tous les jours il marche très très bien
encore donc il y a pas de d'urgence non
plus à les envoyer areem mais en tout
cas au bout de en point de sortie on
aura ces engins également areem ça
apporte beaucoup de choses je vous donne
juste une une illustration c'est que si
un coup de feu c'est mon obsession sur
les coups de feu sur les gendarmes bien
évidemment mais si un coup de feu qui
est tiré sur le sur l'engin la tourelle
se met en tourne automatiquement vers la
l'endroit d'où vient le coup de feu donc
c'est concrètement et puis je vous parle
pas du blindage de la télémétrie
laser donc c'est un engin qui qui sera
très polyvalent entre le le de Lacri euh
voir la crise Plus+
euh sur le recrutement alors en fait les
3000 qui ont été annoncé euh c'est
effectivement dans un journal il y a une
quinzaine de jours qui m'a amené le
weekend d'après à sortir euh dans le
même journal en fait dans les 3000 on a
compté enfin ce ceux qui ont affiché les
3000 ont compté les gendarmes adjoint
volontaire qui quittent leur statut de
gendarme volontaire pour devenir
sous-officier de
gendarmerie donc euh
les 3000 c'est pas un bon chiffre c'est
c'est 3000 on a parmi nos gjoint
volontairees on recrute nos
sousofficiers c'est un c'est un une voie
de recrutement importante on a même créé
une voie simplifiée pour des jeunes les
jeunes on les a jusqu'à 6 ans on les
connaît donc c'est un petit peu bête de
leur faire refaire tout le cursus de de
de sélection quand on sait ce qu'ils
valent donc on en recrute un certain
nombre et donc dans les 3000 il y a no g
mat volontaire en réalité on observe un
des départs un peu plus importants mais
c'est quelques centaines et le quelques
c'est c'est c'est c'est pas tous les
doigts d'une main donc on sadapte mais
mais c'est en réalité les RH tous les
jours on a une légère baisse du niveau
de recrutement mais on a un niveau moyen
qui reste à un très très bon niveau euh
pour les officiers comme pour les
officiers avec un un niveau recrutement
j'avais dit à l'Assemblée entre je CIS
entre 5 et 6 ou entre 4 et 5 ça tourne
autour de ces niveaux-l en moyenne donc
on on reste vigilant parce que ce qui
est vrai aujourd'hui il peut ne plus
l'être mais on a un taux de sélection
qui est satisfaisant alors les jeunes
qu'on a dans les écoles c'est pas les
mêmes que ceux d'il y a 20 ans donc
effectivement les instructeurs qui qui
sont à peine plus jeunes que moi ou qui
qui ont 40 ans ou qui il considère que
toute façon tout le monde considère que
les jeunes sont moins bons que que les
anciens à l'époque moi je l'ai entendu
quand j'étais jeune maintenant que je
suis vieux je l'entends toujours donc
voyz ce que je veux dire c'est que en
réalité les jeunes ils sont différents
ou ils sont différents en fait ils son
ben ils écrivent moins bien donc faut
leur apprendre ils courent moins vite
c'est vrai mais quand on parle de
numérique ils comprennent beaucoup plus
vite alors pas tous mais mais bon mais
mais beaucoup bon mais en fait il faut
pas les regarder quand ils entrent il
faut les regarder quand ils sortent à
nous de nous adapter pour pour les de
toute façon on n pas le choix donc on
s'adapte et moi pour aller dans les
écoles je vous garantis que ce que
j'observe par exemple c'est qu'il y a 10
ans les les jeunes que l'on avait il
passaient tous les concours possibles et
ils allaient dans le premier qu'il
réussissaient là les jeunes qu'on dans
les écoles ils voulaient venir chez nous
je sais pas pourquoi et tant mieux et
Pouru que ça dure mais mais les jeunes
ils ont envie après ben c'est pas les
mêmes d'une génération à une autre ça
change on l'observe tous on conta tous
mais il faut les regarder quand ils
sortent en tout cas on on en vire pas
plus qu'avant entre guillemets on en
vire chaque année a des gens qui sont
inadaptés ou qui sont trompés mais bah
les jeunes ils font ce qu'on leur
demande de faire et puis à nous d'être à
la hauteur pour les former donc je moi
j'ai pas d'inquiétude par rapport à ça
et c'est vrai pour nos officiers comme
pour nosoficiers mais le travail
d'instructeur c'est un travail de remise
en cause permanente et et sal les
instructeurs parce que bah c'est oui il
faut il faut le faire il faut accepter
aussi l'idée que que le jeune est
différent mais je en tout cas on est
hyper vigilant mais on n'est pas inquiet
et on les fera les ETP c'est comme pour
les réservistes en fait alors c'est
50000 pas 500000 même si je signerai
volontiers pour les 500000 bon les
500000 on aurait du mal à les faire mais
mais en fait cela étant vous avez raison
parce que comme les réserves augmentent
partout tout le monde crée sa réserve
euh en fait il y a une forme de
concurrence et euh bon après aussi à
nous d'être bon pour pour all chercher
ceux qui nous intéresse jusqu'à présent
ce qui nous gênait c'est qu'on avait pas
les budgets aujourd'hui les budgets on
les a maintenant il faut aussi qu'on
qu'on qu'on repense notre façon d'aller
recruter un réserviste chez nous pour
les deux tiers d'entre eux ne n'ont eu
aucune relation avec la gendarmerie
avant donc c'est pas c'est pas des des
retraités là on va chercher quelques
retraités ça permet d'augmenter plus
vite et puis il y a des gens qui ont pas
forcément pensé mais on va continuer à
chercher les jeunes ça marche et là on a
les crédits donc le en tout cas
l'objectif on tiendra on le tiendra sur
l'immobilier les brigades nouvelles
alors certes on en a 3100 de brigades
donc 239 sur 3100 c'est pas un
pourcentage phénoménal donc c'est pas ce
qui allait générer 1 milliard d'euros en
plus dans le budget monsieur le
rapporteur euh cela étant sur le les 239
brigades il y a sur les saclclages
budgétaires que nous avons sur les
loyers c'est choses qui sont intégré
dans les constructions budgétaires
chaque année donc on saura les
construire al dans les conditions euh je
vais je vais y venir tout de suite euh
sur lequel il va falloir qu'on porte une
attention particulière pour prendre
alors le le je vais pas me substituer à
la relation bailleur euh commune mais
cela étant on regarde tous les sujets
qui se posent et à un moment donné on
regarde comment on peut faire baisser le
coût en en changeant les référentiels ou
en baissant ponctuellement
euh une quelque chose du mère carré ou
euh pour pour essayer de faire en sorte
de de de baisser le coup que soit plus
supportable parce qu'il y a l'inflation
à prend rendre en compte qui n'était pas
le cas avant c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a
demandé à Bercier le ministre l'a obtenu
l'augmentation du du loyer pour qu'en
fait le montage budgétaire se tiennent
en fait c'est ça l'enjeu donc ben on
bouge tous les curseurs que l'on a à la
main sur le sur le les cas que vous
évoquiez c'est c'est un sujet que que
l'on en tête je regarde en rentrant
mais François m'avait déjà glissé les
éléments mais donc c'est des choses que
l'on regarde et on va aider les
collectivités bien évidemment parce que
enfin on s' ensemble puisqueon on on a
vraiment parti lié mais faut on regarde
sur les brigades qui étaient déjà en
cours de construction du fait de
l'inflation notamment parce que les
effectivement budgétairement c'est plus
la même c'est plus la même musique quoi
donc on va regarder et et on voit
comment bouge les curseurs on en sortira
mais sur les véic général je m'excuse
mais j'ai huit questions après 11h si on
peut juste accélérer pour que chacun
puisse
s'exprimer en 2 minutes sur les sur les
véhicules don dont je n'ai pas parlé
effectivement pardon en fait le les
mesures Guerini les mesures générales
le catego et l'inflation à un moment
donné il faut toutes les administration
sont dans la même situation alors oui
2024 il y a des choix à faire et sur les
véhicules on va faire moins de véhicules
en 24 qu'on en a fait en 23 l'année 24
ben on doit assumer quand la lopmie a
été construite personne parlait
d'inflation donc bah il faudra faire des
choix on le sait on va le faire pour
pour pour pour en
sortir sur le budget 25 j'espère qu'on
aura pris en compte le fait qu'on a fait
des choix en 24 pour passer mais on est
on n'est pas les seuls dans cette
situation là et dans le même temps le
pays doit faire des économies donc je
mon rôle c'est c'est de proposer des
choix et je retiens votre remarque et
surtout pour 25 je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on qu'on
fasse soit très très vigilant de pas
reconstruire un budget 25 sur le 24
alors qu'on a dû faire des choix enfin
vous connaissez la c'est la manière de
faire donc voilà monsieur le Président
merci mon Général pardon je propose au
H8 de nos sénateurs qui de nos collègues
sénateurs qui souhaitent poser une
question de faire très court parce qu'on
a le DG à 11h je commence par Olivier
cadick et ce sera ensuite Michell Valy
merci oui c'est sur le programme 129
tout ce qui concerne la cyber mais juste
avant je vois des photos qui me
reviennent du Maroc de ce qui s'est
passé hier devant encore une de nos
emprises diplomatiques j'aimerais savoir
si quel est le niveau de présence des
gendarmes dans nos emprises
diplomatiques pour l'année prochaine si
à quel niveau on est et si une une
prévision de progression euh la
gendarmerie nationale est citée en
exemple pour l'avance qu'elle a prise
notamment par rapport à la police
nationale dans la prévention et le
traitement de la menace cyber vous avez
évalu évoquer vos moyens techniques et
humains mais euh nous ce qui nous
intéresse vous avez parlé de la
discussion avec le com cber et puis le
l'ancy vous avez pas cité les
collectivités locales et donc il y a euh
donc maintenant les cesserts qui sont
arrivés et j'aimerais savoir qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette organisation
des cessur mais
aussi
du du développement
de de la coordination entre les acteurs
est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu un grand
nombre d'acteurs trop grand nombre
d'acteurs qui pourrai créer un risque de
confusion et de dispersion de
moyens la question se pose sur les
coordinateurs avec les ministères
concernés service du Premier ministre
ministère de l'Intérieur le numérique il
y a d'autres ministères à l'image de la
sécurité
routière qui avait été mise comme cause
nationale en 2002 par le Président de la
République
jairak est-ce que vous pensez pas que
l'état de la menace cyber ne
justifierait pas de clarifier notre
dispositif autour d'un coordinateur
unique d'une nouvelle stratégie en
cybersécurité je vous merci bon ça fait
un peu plus qu'une question mais mon
général je vous sa pourouvoir être
concis Michel Valy ensuite mais je vous
appelle la concision je vais faire un
peu moins qu'une question monsieur le
Président Monsieur mon général en
janvier 2022 le président de la
République dans son discours sur la
sécurité avait annoncé un plan
d'investissement et de lutte une des
mesures phares était la mise en place
d'un équivalent numérique de l'appel
17 le lancement du numéro est annoncé
pour mars 2024 avec un partenariat comme
il se doit notamment avec le le
groupeement d'intérêt public
cybermalveillance.gou euh et le
ministère de l'Intérieur financerait à
parité ave que la police nationale et la
gendarmerie on apprendrait maintenant
que ce numéro d'appel serait finalement
entre guillemets seulement une
plateforme numérique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer là-dessus et nous
dire où vous en êtes merci Michell euh
Philippe folio merci monsieur le
Président mon Général euh le 9 juin 2022
le président de la République dans le
département du Tarne annoncé la création
donc de ces nouvelles brigades mobiles
euh était présenté une carte notamment à
titre d'exemple du département avec des
zones de faible densité de présence de
gendarmerie euh bon ensuite il y a des
choix qui ont été faits on aimerait
savoir qui on fait ces choix est-ce que
c'est vous est-ce que c'est le ministère
de l'Intérieur et surtout que ces choix
ne correspondaient pas forcément aux
zones qui avaient été préétablies
c'est-à-dire de faible densité de de de
gendarmes et de manque de présence de
gendarmes et et avec des propositions de
collectivité qui permettait d'aller vers
des éléments d'expérimentation de
brigade mobiles avec des coûts moindres
puisque bon le coût de location d'une
brigade classique c'est aux alentours de
100000 € donc là il y a des propositions
faites presque pour moitié moins donc la
gendarmerie est-elle suffisamment riche
entre guillemets pour choisir l'option
la plus chère par rapport à l'option la
moins
chère enfin Olivier sigolotti pour la
série de 4 merci monsieur le Président
mon
général vous avez évoqué le président
Périn pardon a évoqué en préambule
l'attachement des des élus à la
gendarmerie et notamment aux gendarmes
du du territoire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire un petit point rapide mon
général sur ce qui a été à mon sens une
fausse bonne idée qui n'a donné
satisfaction ni aux gendarmes ni aux
élus et qui a pris l'appellation de
BGE en général je vous laisse répondre
et ensuite il restera quatre questions
merci sur le les emprises Diplo on a
aujourd'hui 91 emprises qui sont enfin
elles sont partagées nous on en a 91 et
on a aujourd'hui 304 gardes de sécurité
diplomatique et 37 gendarmes du GI qui
sont déployés sur ces 91 emprises en
fait on on nanticipe pas d'augmentation
mais on augmente quand il y a un besoin
euh par exemple on est en train de
projeter l'équivalent enfin un peloton
de gendarme mobile au
Niger à kartou on avait renforcé et
avant de de de d'évacuer entre le com
des opérations spéciales et le
GN assez régulièrement il y a des
demandes pour renforcer quand quand il y
a une tension particulière sur une sur
une emprise et et ça se fait très très
vite en fait on a une ressource de gens
que l'on est capable d'engager assez
facilement et quand il faut pour pour
protéger les les par exemple le le au
Niger pour protéger les intérêts
français et qu'on nous demande
l'équivalent enfin un Ploton c'est c'est
ça pose pas de difficulté on c'est des
choses qu'on sait faire très vite donc
donc au gré du besoin on augmente et
j'étais encore en contact avec le
directeur général du Kors qui suit ces
sujets là cette
semaine enfin il y a aucun sujet donc si
ça se tend des pays où ça se tendra on
SAA procheter du monde sur je n'ai pas
parlé des collectivités locales mais en
fait sur le sujet cyber en
réalité comme vous tout le monde en fait
je je partage complètement votre analyse
mais mais je pense qu'il est heureux que
tout le monde en fasse parce que le le
la difficulté c'est que on on a souvent
un réflexe administratif de big is
beautiful donc en gros on met tout le
monde au même endroit et puis tout est
mais en fait sur ce sujet surtout pas
euh parce qu'en fait les vulnérabilités
sont partagées et et et ça va au-delà de
la vulnérabilité c'est aussi la façon
dont on utilise aujourd'hui ENF vous
êtes vous êtes un spécialiste mais le le
le numérique pour pour améliorer la
performance de tout le monde donc il
faut que tout le monde s'y intéresse et
et je pense qu'on ça n'engage ce que je
vais vous dire n'engage que moi mais il
faut qu'on recrute beaucoup plus de
scientifiques alors c'est ce qu'on fait
nous depuis quelques années tous les
deux il se trouvent qu'on est
scientifique là mais euh depuis quelques
années plus de la moitié de nos
officiers recrutés sont des ingénieurs
ou un bac + 5 science dur en fait on a
durci le recrutement des scientifiques
après il faut les garder donc faut
construire des parcours de carrière
après faut qu'on soit faut essayer
d'être bon en rche pour les garder mais
c'est il faut absolument le faire
ensuite une fois que tout le monde fait
des efforts il faut le coordonner
euh je je verrai prochainement le patron
de Lancy mais avec l'ancien patron de
lanc je lui avais dit moi je je mets à
disposition mes cyber enquêteurs pour
travailler avec T collectivités et et
travailler aussi avec ce qu'elles font
et vous avez raison mais sous l'autorité
de Lancy moi j'ai pas de sujet par
rapport à ça je pense que Lancy a un
rôle naturel de coordination et moi ça
moi j'ai plein de chefs j'ai pas de
problème avec le fait d'avoir des chefs
donc il faut le coordonner le le risque
c'est que si on nomme un coordonnateur à
côté de Cuxa soit on va limiter son
champ et on va se rendre compte que le
champ est pas assez large parce que que
pour moi le numérique le champ il est il
est tellement large que rien que de
définir les contours ce sera compliqué
mais en tout cas je donc je sais pas si
c'est la bonne réponse mais en tout cas
il y a a il faut coordonner je pense que
lany c'est c'est beaucoup dans son dans
son périmètre et puis c'est absolument
indispensable mais les enjeux sont juste
phénoménaux je rejoins complètement je
vous suis un peu dans ce que dans ce que
vous dites mais je je rejoins
complètement le le le le fait qu'il faut
qu'on y travaille après je sais pas
quelle sera la bonne la bonne
mesure sur le 17 cyber il y a une
réunion d'ailleurs au cabinet du
ministres il y a peu
euh attendez je je
ouais le sur le 17
cyber en fait bon Assima on travaille
bien sûr la main dans la main avec avec
asima on est on est pas sur une logique
de de de d'appel téléphonique mais on
est sur une une logique par exemple de
bouton sur lequel on appuie sur un site
pour déclencher une réaction et une
prise en compte d'un sujet cyber donc le
le le sujet avant il faut qu'on arrive
déjà à à savoir ce que l'on met derrière
et puis techniquement comment on le fait
pour créer quelque chose qui sera facile
à développer un peu partout c'est le le
le le problème des sujets numériques
c'est que avoir une bonne idée c'est
c'est bien mais si l'idée on on l'a
construit hors sol à un moment donné ça
tombe parce que ça marche pas et c'est
un peu la difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais il y avait encore une réunion cette
semaine dirigée par le directeur de
cabinet du du ministre de l'Intérieur
sur sur sur un sujet pour avec Assima
pour qu'on arrive à trouver la bonne la
bonne mesure et pour être au rendez-vous
tel que ça a été annoncé et moi au
derniers nouvelle on est plutôt au
rendez-vous on est même en train de
définir comment on va faire de la comm
là-dessus pour pour pour pour davantage
donner d'éléments mais je pourrais vous
faire passer si vous voulez un point de
situation euh sur sur où est-ce qu'on en
est aujourd'hui on va je vous enverrai
cela sur le le choix des brigades vous
vous le savez monsieur sénateur il y a
eu une une concertation au préfet
Collectiv é élu euh les commandants de
groupement ont été associés à la
réflexion
euh et et ensuite les options sont monté
au ministère
donc moi il m'est arrivé de discuter
avec les préfets pour le le parfois
affiné au plan opérationnel par rapport
à la la façon dont c'était vu parce que
l'idée était quand même d'avoir un champ
très très large de un champ des
possibles très très
large après le choix c'est pas moi qui
l'ai fait au bout du bout il y a des
endroits où tous les élus nétaient pas
d'accord et à un moment donné il fallait
trancher on a eu par exemple des des
départements où il y avait 4 5 6
propositions de brigade or 200 bon 239
en réalité il y a 100 départements même
si je retire ceux de la la petite
couronne où on n pas de zone de
gendarmerie à un moment donné il fallait
faire des choix alors fix ou
mobile c'est souvent des
considérations opérationnelles qui ont
été qui ont défini le ce qui allait se
faire mais la différence de coût est pas
aussi importante que cela parce que bon
d'une part le coût c'est le le on sera
sur du locatif donc sur le coût du sur
le budget de la gendarmerie ça change
pas fondamentalement la donne la seule
différence ça va être le la taille de
l'Infra en locau de service que l'on
construira mais on on n'est pas sur des
différents DEC qui sont
phénoménales concrètement ce qui a
conduit aussi à avoir 2 tiers de brigade
mobile par rapport à un/ers de brigade
fixe c'est aussi le fait que une brigade
fixe avec une dizaine de gendarmes il
faut il faut la l'intégrer dans son
écosystème parce que une structure à 10
la faire fonctionner au quotidien toute
seule c'est pas possible donc il faut
qu'on voit comment comment le comment on
le gère et comment on gère les
interventions pour une brigade mobile
qui fera aussi des interventions mais
beaucoup moins qu'une brigade fixe elle
va essentiellement se déplacer on on a
moins de contrainte opérationnelle sera
plus facile d'assurer un niveau de
disponibilité de de de patrouille mais
pour autant il faut la mettre à un
endroit où il y aura pas des
interventions toutes les nuits parce que
si elle ne les fait pas on va avoir une
charge chez les brigad d' côté qui vont
délaisser leur zone de comp leur
circonscription à elle donc il y a eu je
on pourra s'en parler si vous le
souhaitez le ça a été une alchimie un
peu compliquée pour savoir quelle était
la la la meilleure option qui qui était
retenue après euh moi je pense qu'on va
découvrir aussi des choses en marchant
il y a peut-être des endroits où on
considérera que il faut changer de
modèle voir un petit peu comment on
adapte la brigade que l'on aura créé ça
c'est des choses que que que qu'on
s'engagera à faire on ça ça a été évoqué
notamment lors de certains déplacements
du ministre dans les départements
euh il y a des endroits
où c'est aussi une une richesse qui a
pas été relevée il y a des endroits où
on va être capable d'installer par
exemple un noyau de cavalier parce qu'on
considérera qu'il faudra des chevaux
pour surveiller une zone on y a pas
pensé mais on pourra le faire après il y
a d'autres endroits où on voudra avoir
des motos vertes pour être plus
performant sur des zones qui sont pas
accessibles autrement tout ça en fait on
adaptera au au fil du temps on se donne
le temps de le faire aujourd'hui on est
capable de tout faire isolément on sait
faire une brigade nautique on sait faire
un poste à cheval on sait faire une
brigade motorisée et ben on sait faire
un mélange de tout ça donc on verra
ensuite concrètement
mais la la côe retenue elle est elle est
globalement ça a été le moins mauvais
système mais tout le monde n'a pas eu il
y a eu plus de demandes et je suis
content qu'on demande plus de
gendarmerie que mais à un moment donné
il faut faire un choix quoi choisir
c'est renoncer après si bon on pourra se
voir si concrètement vous avez vous avez
un un point particulier vous souhaitez
que vous souhaitez évoquer
euh sur la BGE alors en fait la la BGE
c'est un système qui permet
théoriquement d'avoir la patrouille à
l'endroit où il va se passer quelque
chose on a un algorithme qui explique
que les les les zones où il se passent
des choses c'est plutôt là là ou là et
donc l'idée c'est de mieux organiser le
service pour avoir le gendarme à
l'endroit où il se passe ce qui permet
notamment la nuit d'avoir moins de
patrouille plutôt que d'essayer de
couvrir tout le département à des
endroit il se passe rien et puis euh et
puis les gens qui dorment la nuit ils
bossent le jour donc il peutvent faire
davantage de proximité de contact le
jour sauf que ça a été dans pas mal de
départements plutôt dévoyé
euh parce que on s'est dit bah tiens il
y a des patrou qui sont dehors on va les
faire tourner partout donc ils font les
suig glaces à toute la ils tournent
toute la nuit Eton alors pourquoi alors
donc en fait c'est pas ça le système
logiquement les patrouilles les
patrouilles du du du dispositif de
gestion des événements desge ell elles
doivent ne pas bouger
donc et en fait mais dans les faits dans
la vraie vie le centre opérationnel
surtout dans département pas très
important il y a deux gendarmes la nuit
et donc il gère l'appel des usagers
l'intervention le retour de
l'intervention donc en fait il gère trop
de choses et c'est plus facile d'engager
la patrouille donc on est en train de
renforcer les effectifs dans les centres
opérationnels pour que chacun enfin que
que ce soit pas le seul multitâche qui
gère tout entre entre 22h et 2h du matin
pour avoir un vrai raisonnement
opérationnel donc le DGE pour l'instant
je on fait de proche en proche mais
l'idée c'est d'arriver au dispositif
idéal au lieu de mettre cinq patrouilles
pour tout couvrir on met trois
patrouilles qui est là où il se passe
quelque chose quand il y a un truc qui
se produit là où il se passe quelque
chose trois fois par an et ben on
réveille les gendarmes de la brigade qui
sont le chien qui abois le les problèmes
enfin les trucs très malheureusement
très classiques on fait intervenir les
gendarmes qui sont d'astreintes mais
plus proche et on garde les patrouilles
aux endroits où il se passe des choses
donc on on j'ai j'ai le constat on l'a
on l'a identifié on on augmente la
capacité d'intelligence de l'opération
de l'opérationnel et puis ensuite on on
fera en sorte d'arriver à quelque chose
qui marchera comme ça avait été
conçu bien mon général je vous laisse je
laisse les quatre derniers intervenants
poser leurs questions rapide je rappelle
qu'il reste 5 minutes question réponse
comprise si on veut pas fâcher le DGA et
qu'on veut continuer à avir du matériel
il faut quand même qu'on le prenne pas
trop en retard merci donc la parole est
à Joë
guerillot
en général nous avons une société qui
évolue avec invillissement de la
population les on cherche à faire en
sorte que les personnes en vieillissant
restent le plus longtemps possible à
domicile ça fait une population
extrêmement fragile souvent victime
d'abus de
faiblesse et et de confiance avec des
conséquences dramatiques et puis des des
gang des des organisations très
orientées sur ce type de population
parce que la la Punité très fréquemment
au coin de la rue en la matière avec une
justice qui est plutôt
lente résultat comment faire aujourd'hui
pour s'adapter à cette situation comment
assurer des actions de prévention parce
qu'une fois que le mal est fait
malheureusement sur des personnes dont
l'esérance de vie est relativement
faible ça a des conséquences
dramatiques est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
utiliser la
réserve citoyenne pour faire des actions
de sensibilisation eu égard à la
mobilisation des gendarmes sur d'autres
d'autres actions et au fait que la
gendarmerie en la matière a beaucoup à
faire dans bien des domaines peut-être
faudrait-il avoir un axe réserve
citoyenne sur les actions donc auprès de
ces population
vulnérable
euh Giselle jourd merci
président général moi je souhaiterais
donc
vous interrogez par rapport au risques
terroristes je suis du département de
l'ude et de la ville de trèbe Don on
sait très bien que le terrorisme ça
frappe aussi dans la ruralité ça peut
faire des drames je souhaitais savoir
moi s'il y avait eu une montée en
puissance en ce qui concerne le
renseignement des dans les dans dans nos
gendarmeries au plus proches des
concitoyens puisque nous voyons
apparaître maintenant beaucoup de de de
de tag antisémite même en milieu rural
voilà merci Giselle Michel gréum
merci alors moi je voulais simplement
intervenir dans le cadre de la
fidélisation des gendarmes j'ai appris
que le ministre de l'intérieur gerérard
tamanin a été sollicité concernant un
gros problème dans les gamies notamment
dans la gestion des ressources humaines
et notamment dans celui de
l'île-de-fance il y aurait des erreurs
ou des retards dans les déroulements de
carrière donc dans les salaires donc je
voulais savoir éventuellement la source
du problème et ce qui a été mis en place
pour régler ce problème merci
merci Michel et pour terminer Sylvie
gach merci président général je me
permets d'insister sur l'obsolescence
des véhicules utilisés par nos gendarmes
véhicules de plus en plus sollicités
avec des zones d'action qui peuvent
atteindre presque le quart de d'un
département néanmoins ma question
concerne plus la protection de nos
gendarmes aujourd'hui les délinquants
utilisent de plus en plus souvent des
armes de
guerre il est à craindre qu'avec le
conflit en Ukraine de nouvelles armes
arrive sur notre sol hein via les
Balcans notamment euh je voudrais savoir
comment la gendarmerie s'adapte euh à
cette nouvelle
configuration mon
général je vous en prie alors sur le
sujet de la viement de vieillissement de
la population euh vous avez raison on a
euh essayé de de de de de segmenter le
travail sur les réponses que l'on peut
apporter pour les personnes les plus
vulnérables donc on a euh on a fait
quelque chose pour
les les les les femmes victimes enfin
surtout les femmes victimes de de
violence au sein des couples sur les les
enfants euh et sur les personnes âgé
euh c'est une réflexion qu'on porte et
et on est on est en train de chercher
quelque chose qui permettrait de le
faire le halz vert que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure va nous permettre d'aller à
certains endroits dans dans des dans
dans les épades dans les d'aller au
contact d'aller euh pour pour pour faire
de la prévention mais mais en fait il
faut qu'on il faut qu'on constise une
doctrine je suis assez d'accord avec
vous et c'est vrai que la réserve
citoyenne pourrait pourrait nous aider
donc on va je je vais mettre ça dans la
liste des des des des
considérants il faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose à un moment donné on pensait à des
des spécialistes également dans les dans
les territoires mais honnêtement moi
j'avais pas pensé au réservis citoyens
donc on va on va regarder mais c'est une
préoccupation et vous avez raison la
population vieillliit et puis
aujourd'hui les les truants on en
parlait tout à l'heure sont de plus en
plus malins et c'est c'est facile
d'ameçonner quelqu'un donc je je peux
malheureusement pas tre plus précis que
ça mais pardon c'est très lâche et
efficace oui oui absolument non mais
vous avez complètement raison donc c'est
un sujet qu'on a en tête mais on a on n
pas trouvé quelque chose qui était
aujourd'hui satisfaisant j'avais pas
répondu à la doctrine sur les réserves
oui il y a une doctrine sur les réserves
bien évidemment et on a d'autres idées
mais ça peut renvoyer d'ailleurs la la
question que vous posiez moi j'ai même
une idée du réserviste que l'on
appellera pour montrer du bleu tout de
suite quand il se passe quelque chose
parce qu'il a chez lui son uniforme et
on a fait passer un décret il y a pas
très long il y a une dizaine de jours
qui permet à C à ces réservistes de
garder leur armes chez eux alors on fera
pas avec tous les réservistes mais
accessirement tout le monde a des armes
à la maison mais on est capable de
sécuriser le le fait d'avoir une arme
chez soi mais on a on a des chasseurs on
a en gros on prendra des gens que que
l'on connaît qui qui pourront garder
dans dans un coffre qu'on leur fournira
leur leur armes et quand il se passera
quelque chose on les appellera en disant
tu es chez toi bah écoute va à la mairie
qui a été visitée déjà tu montres du
bleu en attendant que patrou il arrive
commence à prendre les identités des
gens qui sont qui sont là ou qu'il
faudra entendre parce qu'ils ont vu
quelque chose et ça permettra d'avoir
quelqu'un rapidement sur place ça
permettra d'avoir quelqu'un qui sera
reconnu comme étant aussi un gendarme
parce que régulièrement il mettra la
tenue et ça aura un effet de bord même
quand il ne travaille pas comme pour un
gendarme d'active quand il est en civil
ou quand il est dans son club de foot
tout le monde sait qu'il est gendarme et
ça produit de l'effet aussi de de
sécurisation donc donc on a une doctrine
et c'est aussi un moyen qui permett sans
doute en fait c'est les 300 derniers
mètres quoi donc on a comme ça quelques
idées bon j'en ai pas parlé parce que il
faut conceptuellement encore un peu le
construire mais il nous manquait le
décret pour le maintien de l'arme donc
en gros le policier en retraite gendarme
en retraite ou ou des ou des gens les
tireurs sportifs des gens qui ont un
rapport à l'arme tel qu'on le souhaite
mais nos réservices sont formés à cela
donc donc voilà donc on y travaille et
on aura sans doute quelques du coup une
possibilité d'aller au plus près assez
rapidement donc bon il faut juste
entourer toutes les les précautions
nécessaires sur ces sujetslà euh madame
sur les sujets Teros oui effectivement
malheureusement on l'a encore vu
récemment à ras et puis on le voit avec
tous les T tous les actes que l'on
observe ces derniers temps euh le
aujourd'hui le le le renseignement
territorial et je le dis d'autant plus
que je suis actionnaire minoritaire si
je dis du renseignement territorial ça
marche bien et tous les les les les les
les patrons du renseignement territorial
que que j'ai connu ont bien compris
l'intérêt d'utiliser les modes de
fonctionnement différents des gens des
policiers pour pour pour bonifier ce qui
remonte et a il y a plus de sujet il y
en a eu quand on l'a créé c'est vrai
mais là il y a plus de sujet donc tout
le monde est très vigant là-dessus et on
faitonter tous les éléments en terme de
moyen alors mais en terme de moyen nous
le le notre agent de renseignement c'est
le gendarme de base si je dire j'aime
pas cette expression mais c'est aussi le
réserviste c'est celui qui voit quelque
chose après celui qui élabore qui qui
qui qui analyse ce qui se passe c'est le
renseignement territorial et la DGSI et
donc moi mon rôle c'est de faire en
sorte que tout remonte il remonte à
l'endroit où onanalyse on est même en
train de travailler sur un petit un
petit logiciel sur néo qui permettra en
fait d'aller un peu plus loin dans
laarmonter d'info pour faire remonter
très simplement des des des des signaux
faibles pour qu'on puisse ensuite les
analyser et même de les faire un peu
mouliner pour avoir des alerte aux
endroits où il se passent des choses pas
prévues mais j'en ai pas parlé non plus
parce qu'il y y a un peu de travail de
développement et et on va pas le faire
dans leis dans le mois qui suit quoi
donc mais c'est c'est une obsession de
tout le
monde sur la filation alors les
ne nous gère pas nous en fait il gère
nos civils mais le ministre a souhaité
donner au DG au responsables de
programme davantage de de capacité de
gestion de le personnel civil donc moi
les à part à part les 5000 civils que
que les gamigè les 95000 autres sont
gérés par les par la DGGN et ça se passe
ça se passe bien ça se passe ça se passe
plutôt pas mal même si ça passe jamais
trop bien euh
mais sur le nos personnels civils on est
en train de reprendre la main moi je
vois très régulièrement nos
organisations syndicales et c'est un
sujet du secrétaire général mais on
travaille la main dans la main sur ce
sujets donc alors leami Paris c'est vrai
que c'est le dernier c'est compliqué
puis c'est c'est il y a quand même
beaucoup de monde mais sur les sujets
don don dont vous parlez on les a pas
mesuré chez
nous l'obsesence des véhicules madame la
sénatrice alors c'est moins vrai que ça
ne l'était C des dernières années parce
on a vu quand même fleurir plein de
véhicules neufs les 5008 que vous voyez
les 3008 les euh les kodiaques les euh
on a on a en fait beaucoup de voitures
neuves qui sont arrivés alors c'est vrai
que cette année on baisse le nombre de
véhicules euh c'est pour ça qu' j'espère
qu'on les remontera assez vite pour
garder un flux euh euh mais on regarde
ça de près et c'est vrai qu'il tourne
beaucoup donc ça mais on c'est quelque
chose qu'on garde de près sur les moyens
de protection euh après Amber on a on a
engagé un processus de d'élévation du
niveau d'équipement donc on a développé
un un gilet ce qu'on appel un gilet 3
en1 qui fait gilet par bas les gilet où
on peut accrocher les équipements dont
on a besoin qui est modulable à savoir
qu'on met des plaques de kevelard à la
hauteur de la menace donc on peut il y a
pas le même poids on n'est pas obligé de
porter 50 kg sur soi quand il s'agit
d'aller faire quelque chose où le risque
est quand même très limité d'ailleurs
les gendarmes vous les voyez globalement
ils les portent tout le temps leur
gilets même en été quand il fait très
chaud et et les gilets sont plus
confortables alors il faut qu'on arrive
sur des gilets lourds plus lourds dans
les cas graves et des casques euh on en
a pas mis partout encore on on on d'utes
les PSIG et puis petit à petit euh en
tache d'huile on dote également les les
euh les les brigades mais vous avez
raison c'est un vrai c'est un vrai sujet
de préoccupation et et moi c'est mon
sujet vraiment principal
quoici je si je peux me permettre juste
de de saluer le sénateur con parce que
on on se on se parlait souvent de ces
sujets-là et puis je je je vous aperçois
maintenant et voilà voilà monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup pardon merci
beaucoup mon général c'était une
audition importante
qui compte tenu du contexte de la montée
des violences de toute nature dans notre
pays était était aussi avait aussi
beaucoup de sens a beaucoup de sens et
on retient évidemment votre évaluation
d'une contestation de plus en plus
importante et systématique de l'ordre
républicain on en blaguit en disant s'il
n avait pas de gendarmes il y aurait pas
de garde à vue mais malheureusement
semble que les contestations soient de
plus en plus nombreus et les gendarmes
au premier rang des de ceux qui parfois
sont les victimes de ce genre de
violence donc nos rapporteurs ont fait
part des préoccupations de leur
préoccupation de notre commission
également sur les
moyens et je pense que chacune à chacun
d'entre nous ici se reconnaîtra dans le
voilà dans l'hommage que dans la
reconnaissance que je voulais avoir et
que donc que j'ai fait en début de au
début de mes propos en direction de des
hommes et des femmes de la gendarmerie
qui au quotidien dans l'ensemble de de
nos communes rural et bien sont parfois
le dernier service public auquel on a
affaire donc je vous souhaite évidemment
de réussir à mettre en œuvre ce que le
président de la République vous a
demandé de mettre en œuvre c'est vrai
que si on pouvait voir un peu plus de
bleu ce serait pas mal mais parfois j'ai
l'impression quand même que c'est pas
gagné et c'est une remarque qu'on entend
au fur et à mesure des dgges qui sont
succédés à cette à cette place la
volonté d'être plus souvent sur le
terrain mais malheureusement pour les
élus qui comme moi sont dans le dans la
ruralité la plus profonde on a parfois
l'intention des difficultés à avoir de
bleu donc on espère que ces ces ces
demandes seront mises en application
avec les moyens qui vous sont attribués
qui vraisemblablement sont assez
satisfaisants vous permettront de mettre
en œuvre cette politique en tout cas
merci pour votre vos propos pour cette
audition et puis rendez-vous à la à la
prochaine prochaine audition merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le
président